que faire des émissions est ce que ça
vous est arrivé de dire voilà je suis
pas bien jamais jamais surtout surtout
pas le faire
jamais jamais de la vie jamais de la vie
il ya des animateurs ya jean luc delarue
par exemple mais jean-luc que je
connaissais un peu il
il a toujours reconnu qu'il utilisait la
fête que le club vendredi puis après il
a fait la fête le jeudi et le vendredi
après le jeudi vendredi samedi et
dimanche et forcément le mardi il dit
qu'il est mal au dos pour aller à
l'émission mais c'est pas que lui c'est
le cycle c'est malheureusement j'ai
qu'un grain de sable celui qu'on est
moins bien et moi j'étais vieux sam a
été protégée de saoro nous mais j'aurais
pu tomber dedans comme comme comme
d'autres ça n'a pas été le cas bon voilà
très bien mais si moi je ne sortais pas
j'allais pas en boîte j'avais pas si
j'étais chez moi que des copains donc
c'est déjà le cas de vos protège quand
même voilà sur iliad animateurs qui m'a
dit l'animateur un jour qui m'a dit on
peut pas faire une grande carrière
sinon c'est impossible si on s'est un
peu sur ses impressions et les
autochtones heures et c'est vrai que
jean lui et vous étiez son dealer ouais
j'ai luc delarue et c'est vrai que
c'était ça a été l'un des exemples les
plus connus à la télévision il en est
bien décédé vous étiez son dealer vous
dites dont jean luc delarue quand ce
qu'est ce que c'est lui qui vous a
sollicité
ah oui merci rue bien sûr mais c'était
comment dire elle c'était le bouche à
oreille toi moi j'allais aux bains
douches et le baril n'est pas ce qu'il a
dit là c'est très pertinent c'est tout à
fait ça on se prendre dans un cercle
vicieux
on est fatigué le lendemain on doit
aller au boulot alors on reprendre la
toque et bien comme ça et ça s'arrête
pas mais ce que dit ophélie winter
condamnant prend vous lui reprochez pas
vrai que c'est vrai mais vraiment
aujourd'hui je sais pas mais je veux
dire moi je parle des années 80
pratiquement toi ça a changé un parce
que ça s'est popularisé c'est ce que
maintenant c'est 80 félicité
la grande découverte c'était comment
dirais-je y avait des c'est comme si on
avait découvert l'amérique tout le monde
se souvient l'américain non mais ça
dépend gérard vous regrettez tout ça ou
pas fan on ne regrette pas pendant
trente ans mais moins bien parce que ça
coûtait la vie quand même
jean luc delarue ça doit coûter la vie
ouais mais lui l'a bien cherché aussi il
faut dire que l'huile apprenait en
sarbacane et moi je dis effet pas compte
qu'ils voient de choper d'ailleurs comme
bernard tapie on ne va pas chercher loin
puisque c'est pareil les cancers de les
autres bernard tapie comment vous pouvez
pas dire ça sur berlin je l'aï dit dans
mon bouquin je sais oui je sais dans
bernard aujourd'hui malade j'ai
simplement que quand on se chope un
cancer de l'oesophage
on ne sait pas eu de l'estomac et des
intestins ça vient et la réalité il ya
plein de gens qui n'ont jamais rien pris
aux tripes malheureusement un concer
nant très franchement pour bernard tapie
je vous reprends parce que je vous l'aï
dit dans votre livre c'est vrai que j'ai
dit dans mon goût et mais ça fait
brosser lui il dit que son cancer est
largement due au stress qu'on lui a
infligé par les process arts le fait de
se faire des noeuds à l'estomac sarah
aurait déclenché ça donc je vous dis
rares labo team sky dans ce métier où la
vis bien sûr qu'il stresse donc mais il
ya beaucoup de stress en prenant de la
coke aussi un faux pas oublié oui en
tout cas de la rue pour rester sur de la
rue je lui dis mais la coke c'est fait
pour édifier une c'est vrai mais j'ai
les fosses nasales arrachés ah oui
normal j'ai dit si tu vas te coucher
avec tu prends deux kits 2 g de
bourdeilles tu vas te coucher la nuit
sans te laver le truc avec une solution
saline forcément le lendemain ça te
ronge la cocaïne c'est fait mais c'est
fait avec de l'acide chlorhydrique la
cauquenne faut le savoir et de la chaux
à la base donc c'est des produits mais
bien sûr c'est des produits qui sont
comme pourquoi en fait ça fait quoi je
sais ça fait quoi si les fausses le
hamas alors provoqué quoi jean luc
dehors il sentait dans un far 161 points
de confiance en soi de l'euphorie à huy
aux favoris a évidemment